[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg schönen guten Abend und
willkommen schön dass Sie dabei sind wie
auch Norbert Lehmann für den Sportplatz
die Unterstützer der Ukraine haben sich
heute in Ramstein getroffen
Entscheidung verschoben noch will
Deutschland keine Leopard Panzer an die
Ukraine liefern sondern erst einmal die
Bestände prüfen und sich mit Partnern
absprechen
auf der Suche nach Fachkräften mit einer
neuen Strategie will die Regierung eins
der drängendsten Probleme hierzulande in
den Griff bekommen
und wer soll das bezahlen die rasant
gestiegenen Preise für Obst Gemüse und
andere Lebensmittel sind auch auf der
Grünen Woche ein Top-Thema
[Musik]
groß waren die ukrainischen Hoffnungen
an das Treffen in Ramstein mit
Vertretern aus über 50 Ländern von einem
entscheidenden Moment im Kampf sprach
der US-Außenminister und war für weitere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine die gibt
es auch massiv nicht nur aus den USA
aber ob die Ukraine auch deutsche
Leopard 2 Kampfpanzer bekommt das lässt
der Bundeskanzler nach wie vor offen
Thomas Reichert
die Begrüßung für den neuen ist
freundlich aber die Erwartung an ihn
hoch nicht nur beim amerikanischen und
ukrainischen Verteidigungsminister auch
bei ukraines Präsident selenski der an
die Runde in Ramstein und an einen
nachdenklichen Boris Pistorius
appelliert
es steht in ihrer Macht aus Rammstein
heraus Panzer zu senden nicht zu
falschen über die Anzahl sondern sich
grundsätzlich für diese Lieferungen zu
öffnen um das Böse aus Russland zu
stoppen
vor Beginn sah man Deutschlands
Verteidigungsminister minutenlang
draußen telefonieren offenbar gab es
noch einiges zu klären doch was
Pistorius später verkündet es gerade
nicht das was selenski sich wünschte
Deutschland entscheidet nicht es prüft
ich möchte dann wenn einer Entscheidung
fällt ob in einer Woche oder in zwei
oder in einem Tag gehen in der Lage sein
auch schnell handeln zu können deswegen
habe ich heute morgen meinem Haus den
Auftrag erteilt eine Prüfung vorzunehmen
über die Bestände von Leopard Panzern
der verschiedenen Typen in Berlin sorgt
die Nachricht für Sie Verwunderung die
Zahl der Leopard Panzer sollte bekannt
sein die Forderung der Ukraine ebenfalls
sie brauchen Ersatz und sie können auf
diesen Ersatz leider nicht ewig warten
dementsprechend muss auch Deutschland
seine Prüfung irgendeinem irgendwann
einmal abschließen das Statement hat
mich fassungslos zurückgelassen der
Verteidigungsminister steht mit leeren
Händen da ich weiß nicht was jetzt noch
geprüft werden soll
Pistorius Zurückhaltung findet in Berlin
vor allem die AFD gut
bislang ist positiv zu bewerten dass er
dem Druck auch innerhalb der Koalition
standhält der Kriegstreiberei von FDP
und grün was Deutschland in der Ramstein
heute verspricht ist schon bekannt die
Lieferung von 40 Marder Schützenpanzern
eines patriot-flug Abwehrsystems
insgesamt helfen im Wert von gut einer
Milliarde Euro der
US-Verteidigungsminister lobt
Deutschland dafür und fordert
gleichzeitig noch mehr ja wir können
alle noch mehr tun Deutschland ist ein
zuverlässiger Verbündeter und ist das
schon seit sehr langer Zeit und ich
glaube wirklich dass Sie auch in Zukunft
ein zuverlässiger Verbündeter sein
werden
die panzerentscheidung wird am Ende
Scholz treffen die nächste Möglichkeit
wäre der deutsch-französische
Ministerrat am Sonntag
haben wir Theo call in Berlin warum tut
sich der Bundeskanzler so schwer mit
dieser leopard-entscheidung
also mein Eindruck ist es der Kanzler
lieber internationale Prügel und
Ansehensverlust den Kauf nimmt als die
für sich festgelegte Linie der
eskalationsvermeidung zu verlassen er
möchte einfach keine wichtigen
militärischen Schritte oder die USA
gehen ob das nun jungtim heißt oder auch
strategischer Gleichschritt unter
scheint es egal ob die USA amerikanische
Abrams Panzer liefern oder vergleichbar
bedeuten des Kampfgerät entscheidend ist
für Olaf scholzes Joe Biden jeden
wichtigen militärischen Schritt mitgeht
und daran hat auch der heutige Druck aus
dem US-Verteidigungsministerium
offensichtlich nichts geändert denn dort
hätte man eine leopardlieferung ohne
gleichwertige amerikanische Leistung
durchaus begrüßt
der neue Verteidigungsminister will
jetzt erstmal den Bestand der Panzer
prüfen lassen da fragt man sich
natürlich warum das nicht längst
passiert ist absolut das macht auch hier
nicht wenige in Berlin wahlweise Rat
oder fassungslos denn die erste
offizielle bitte der Ukraine nach
Kampfpanzern die ging ja schon acht Tage
nach Kriegsbeginn im Kanzleramt ein also
Anfang März 2022 wenn es stimmt das ist
noch immer keine Übersicht über die
Bestände gibt dann ist es natürlich ein
unfassbares Versäumnis dann wurde da
fast ein Jahr zeitenwände sehr
unzureichend genutzt für den neuen
Verteidigungsminister ist es auf der
einen Seite eine bittere Erkenntnis über
den Zustand der Vorbereitung in seinem
Ministerium und zugleich hat er das
heute auch genutzt um sich vom Lambrecht
Erbe abzusetzen
Dankeschön für diese Informationen aus
Berlin teokoll war das
der Kreml hat längst wissen lassen dass
westliche Kampfpanzer Russland nicht
stoppen würden und nicht am Erreichen
seiner Kriegsziele hindern würden das
sieht nicht nur die Ukraine anders wann
und warum der Leopard 2 möglicherweise
einen Unterschied machen könnte zeigt
Kristina gründgen
der Leopard 2 ist ein deutscher
Exportschlager 14 europäische Länder
sind im Besitz von insgesamt gut 2000
Panzern nicht alle sind einsatzbereit
nicht alle Länder lassen sich bei der
Anzahl in die Karten schauen Deutschland
soll rund 320 Leopard 2 besitzen am
meisten hat wohl Spanien mit fast 350
Finnland hat etwa 200 Modelle Polen das
am stärksten auf die Lieferung an die
Ukraine drängt besitzt nach eigenen
Angaben 247 Stück der Leopard 2 gilt als
einer der modernsten und
schlagkräftigsten Kampfpanzer der Welt
den russischen Panzern ist der technisch
überlegen für eine erfolgreiche gegen
Offensive fordert der ukrainische
Generalstab 300 Kampfpanzer mit
mindestens 100 wäre es laut Experten
aber schon möglich die Front punktuell
zu durchbrechen dann wird die russische
Front zumindest an einem bestimmten
Abschnitt kollabieren und deswegen
gamechanger also das ist dann nicht nur
um eine Initiative sondern eben es ist
ein wirkliches Durchbrechen der Front
und ein Zurückdrängen der Russen dazu
kommt es nicht allein auf die Zahl
einsatzbereiter Panzer an ukrainische
Soldaten müssen geschult werden die
Versorgung mit Ersatzteilen und
Treibstoff organisiert und die Zeit
drängt es geht nicht darum wie lange es
dauern könnte es geht darum auf welchen
Moment Sie das Ganze benötigen nämlich
auf das Zeitfenster April Mai also wenn
dir das putica die schlangenperiode
vorbei ist und dann die
Frühjahrsoffensive losgeht bis dahin
müssen die Crews trainiert sein die
Systeme da sein die Logistikkette muss
stehen das so Kolb sei durchaus noch
machbar aber dafür müsste eine Gruppe
von Staaten jetzt gemeinsam loslegen
aber soweit ist es noch nicht es gab
auch heute keine Entscheidung zu den
Kampfpanzern Kathrin Eigendorf in Kiew
wie wird das in der Ukraine aufgenommen
schon mit einer gewissen Enttäuschung in
der Öffentlichkeit denn die Erwartungen
waren ja sehr hoch und Präsident
selensky hatte ja wiederholt klar
gemacht wie wichtig der Leopard 2 für
die Ukraine in diesem Krieg ist Russland
kämpft zwar mit veralteter Technologie
aber eben mit sehr viel mit sehr viel
Technologie und da kann nur moderne
Waffen eine Änderung herbeiführen was
aber interessant ist vor wenigen Minuten
hat Präsident selenski selber die
Entscheidung und der Ereignisse in
Rammstein kommentiert und er hat gesagt
dass er eigentlich das Gesamtpaket was
dort verabschiedet wurde sehr erfreulich
sieht und das für die Ukraine ein
Zeichen ist dass die westlichen Partner
doch die Militärhilfe leisten die die
Ukraine braucht und er sie sagte dass er
selbst im Bezug auf den Leopard die
Chance sieht dass ich da noch etwas tut
und das die Ukraine diese Technologie
doch noch rechtzeitig erhält was hier in
der Ukraine allerdings für sehr viel
Misstrauen sorgt und gibt auch
Regierungskreise immer wieder besorgt
ist dass man der Bundesregierung und vor
allem dem Kanzler unterstellt doch
geleitet zu sein von einer großen Angst
vor Wladimir Putin das Deutschland immer
noch nicht verstanden hat dass man mit
Angst nicht weiterkommt dass das nicht
die richtige Politik ist das wird hier
sehr kritisch gesehen danke Katrin
Eigendorf live aus Kiew
alles zur Debatte über mögliche
kampfpanzerlieferungen und was
Deutschland an Ausrüstung bereits an die
Ukraine geschickt hat zusammengefasst in
der ZDF heute App oder auf heute.de
nicht nur militärisch braucht die
Ukraine Hilfe sondern auch für den
Wiederaufbau dafür will die
Bundesregierung noch mal 52 Millionen
Euro bereitstellen
entwicklungsministerin Schulze die
gestern in Odessa war hat angekündigt
das Geld werde unter anderem für
Wärmestuben und Generatoren ausgegeben
bei ihrem Besuch machte sie sich ein
Bild von den Zerstörungen und dem
Wiederaufbau und besuchte auch ein
Hilfszentrum für Kinder
um fehlende russisches Gas zu
kompensieren setzt Deutschland auch auf
schwimmende
lng-terminals zwei sind bereits in
Betrieb ein drittes kam am Vormittag in
Brunsbüttel an das Spezialschiff kann
verflüssigtes Erdgas von Tankern
aufnehmen und in gas zurückverwandeln
mit dem dritten Terminal gebe es nun
eine Kapazität von 14 Milliarden
Kubikmeter Gas pro Jahr sagte
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck das ist ein
Viertel von dem was früher über die
Pipeline Nord Stream 1 nach Deutschland
kam
ob im Handwerk in der Gastronomie oder
in der Pflege überall fehlen helfende
Hände was ist dagegen zu tun darüber
diskutierte heute der Bundestag denn auf
dem deutschen Arbeitsmarkt werden bis
2035 mehr als 7 Millionen Fachkräfte
fehlen auch weil die geburtenstarken
Jahrgänge bald in Rente gehen die
Bundesregierung setzt jetzt auf mehr aus
und Fortbildung mehr Frauen in
Vollzeitjobs und auf gezielte
Einwanderung Svenja Domeyer
ist Krankenpflegerin aus Tunesien Martin
Herrera hat in Kolumbien Medizin
studiert seit einigen Monaten arbeiten
beide in dieser
intensivpflege-wg in Hannover die
Perspektive in ihren Herkunftsländern
ist schwierig ein Job in Deutschland für
sie eine Chance das Gesundheitssystem
hier in Deutschland ist entwickelt als
Indonesien ich bin zufrieden kannst
zufrieden ich würde gerne hier als
Radiologe Arbeiten ich will meine eigene
Firma irgendwann der Chef des
Pflegedienstes rekrutiert Personal
weltweit vor allem die formelle
Abwicklung müssen schneller und besser
klappen sagt er allein einen Termin bei
der Ausländerbehörde zu bekommen sei oft
kaum möglich für uns ist es frustrierend
für die
Betroffenen ist das ein hoher
Stressfaktor die haben einfach Angst äh
das Land verlassen zu müssen Dauer Thema
Fachkräftemangel im Bundestag
diskutieren sie heute neue Strategien
die Regierung plant eine Ausbild
Offensive und setzt auf qualifizierte
Einwanderung wir müssen auch die
Bürokratie abbauen in diesem Bereich das
betrifft die Visa-Vergabe die Frage von
Sprachkursen und wir müssen eins im
Gedächtnis halten es kommen nicht nur
Arbeitskräfte es kommen Menschen
deutschland brauche eine
anwerbestrategie und
Integrationsangebote reichlich spät
kritisiert die Opposition das Problem
sei hausgemacht Jahr
elang zu billig wie möglich sein und das
hat dem fachkräftestandort massiv
geschadet mit der einwanderungsreform
könnte es für ausländische Arbeitskräfte
bald einfacher werden am 1 märz ist das
Bundeskabinett am Zug und stimmt über
den Gesetzentwurf ab
mir gerade auf einen Brief oder Pakete
wartet braucht Geduld ben ben bei der
Deutschen Post wird gestreikt die
Gewerkschaft Verdi rief ihre Mitglieder
in allen Brief und paketzzentren auf die
Arbeiten die dazu legen laut Post sind
bundesweit rund 2,3 Millionen Pakete und
13 Millionen Briefe betroffen die
Gewerkschaft fordert 15% mehr Geld bei
einer Laufzeit von einem Jahr morgen
sollen die Zusteller streichen
Krieg und Inflation haben die Preise
nach oben getrieben auch von
Lebensmitteln insgesamt mussten wir im
vergangenen Jahr an der Supermarktkasse
13 Prozent mehr zahlen als noch 2021
deutlich teure wurde zum Beispiel
Sonnenblumen oder Rapsöl plus 64% oder
Butter + 39 Prozent und auch beim Gemüse
stiegen die Preise umfasst 11%. großes
Thema bei der Grünen Woche in Berlin
berichtet Nils Schneider
die Grüne Woche hat die Tore kaum
geöffnet da sind die Hallen schon gut
gefüllt die hohen Lebensmittelpreise
spielen natürlich beim Publikum eine
Rolle egal ob Bio oder konventionell
wenn man keine Wahl wir müssen das Beste
draus machen bisschen sparen nach
Schnäppchen gucken man will ja die
anderen Kosten auch Decken und sich
vielleicht auch trotzdem noch mal in
Urlaub gönnen
wir nehmen das auch was dort wächst und
eingebaut wird und im Winter ist mir
eben das was es immer im Winter gegeben
hat und keine Tomaten auf Höfen wie hier
in Niedersachsen sehen sich viele
Landwirte gezwungen ihre gestiegenen
Kosten an die Verbraucher weiterzugeben
so wie etwa til tevis in seinem
Familienbetrieb in Nienhagen
wir haben aktuell im Vergleich zum
August 2020 60 Prozent höhere
Futterkosten
welche beim JA Schwein mit den größten
Kostenfaktor ausmachen allerdings dann
natürlich auch Energie wesentlich teurer
geworden und auch die Lohnkosten
verbraucherschützer sehen nicht nur
diese Punkte als Preistreiber sondern
vermuten auch der Handel schlägt noch
einmal drauf genau Daten liegen noch
nicht vor es gibt keine vernünftige
Transparenz über Preisbildung im
Lebensmittelmarkt und mindestens das
muss die Bundesregierung jetzt angehen
sich anzuschauen wo überhaupt die
Preissteigerung stattfinden und dr
vielleicht der ein oder andere
übermäßige Gewinner macht außer Preise
vergleichen bleibt VerbraucherInnen also
nicht viel die Lust an gutem Essen und
Trinken ist jedenfalls geblieben und das
wird die nächsten Tage auf der Grünen
Woche gefeiert
[Musik]
jetzt nach Südamerika nach Peru bei
Protesten gegen die Regierung kam es nun
auch in der Hauptstadt Lima zu schweren
Ausschreitungen ein Generalstreik endete
dort in Gewalt und Zerstörung
Demonstranten durchbrachen
Straßensperren Beamte reagierten mit
Tränengas auf der historischen Platz der
St Martin wurde ein Wohnblock in Brand
gesetzt die Demonstranten fordern die
Freilassung von Ex-Präsident castigo und
Neuwahlen
60 Jahre stand er mit seiner Musik im
Rampenlicht nun ist der us-gitarrist und
Sänger David Crosby mit 81 gestorben in
den 60er und 70er Jahren prägte er den
Sound der Hippie Ära mit seinen Bands
the birds und Cros
gleich zwei Mal in die Rock n' Roll
[Musik]
ja gleich zu einer anderen Legende Rudi
Völler Norbert der wollte erst gar nicht
DFB-Sportdirektor werden hat er heute
gesagt hat sie aber offenbar überzeugt
und jetzt ist er auch voll dabei und hat
heute bei seiner offiziellen
Vorstellungen in Frankfurt viel
Optimismus verbreitet er glaube an einen
deutschen Erfolg bei der Heim em 2024
bis dahin aber ein hartes Stück Arbeit
für den Weltmeister von 1990 ein
kleinerer Aufgabenbereich als sein
Vorgänger Bierhoff und die Befristung
bis zur Heim em24 diese beiden Aspekte
haben ihn dann doch ja sagen lassen ich
glaube auch dass ich mit sehr viel Elan
und noch Freude an die Aufgabe angeht
eine von Völlers Vorstellungen dass wir
uns auch etwas näher erfolgsnäher geben
seine Kurzanalyse der verpatzten WM
diesen teamspiriert den Teamgeist der
hat da haben wir natürlich ein paar
Prozent gefehlt
Credo Optimismus hilft aber ich will
immer nur davon überzeugt dass wir eine
Mannschaft haben
die in anderthalb Jahren um den Titel
mitspielen kannst Manifest Überzeugung
Völler will nun ganz in der Rolle des
Retters aufgehen
erster Fußball-Bundesliga Spieltag im
neuen Jahr das Auftakt Match heute abend
Leipzig gegen München ja und vom BVB
kommt diese Nachricht laut Trainer Edin
tersit steht die Vertragsverlängerung
mit dem viel umworbenen Jungstürmer und
Nationalspieler yusufer zeitnah vor er
freue sich auf die weitere
Zusammenarbeit mit dem 18-Jährigen
[Applaus]
zum Ski Alpin Weltcup da landete Thomas
Dresden beim Abfahrtsrennen in Kitzbühel
als bester Deutscher auf Rang 13 und in
Container d'Ampezzo schaffte eskira
weiter zum zweiten Mal in diesem Winter
aufs Podest sie wurde starke dritte
Siegerin die Italienerin Sophia
zur Handball WM da hat das deutsche Team
gestern Abend ja einen furiosen 39 zu 19
Sieg gegen Außenseiter Argentinien
eingefahren morgen Abend geht's im
zweiten haupt-spiel gegen deutlich
stärkere Niederländer
zufriedene Gesichter beim Spaziergang
zur Pressekonferenz heute durch das
verschneitet Kattowitz ein fulminanter
Sieg war das gestern Abend nach der
24.11 Pausenführung bekam auch der
zweite anzugeinsatzzeit und überzeugte
am Ende sogar mit einem 20 Tore
Vorsprung ganz so deutlich wird es gegen
die Niederlande wohl nicht ja das wird
ein schnelles spielen temporäres Spiel
weil die Holländer setzen auch sehr auf
ihre Tempo Spiel die Niederländer schon
heiß auf das Nachbarschaftsduell zu 120%
motiviert die übrigens mindestens
genauso viel
und das Spiel morgen Abend bei uns zu
sehen im ZDF ab 20:15 unbedingt
anschauen wird sicher spannend zum
Schluss noch der Blick auf einen
zugefrorenen See im Norden Japans und
dazu die Frage was könnte hier wohl
Touristen anlocken
Schlittschuhlaufen war den
Verantwortlichen zu banal und so kam sie
auf die Idee mit dem eiskarussell eine
Scheibe ausgeschnitten die Ränder
abgeschliffen und dann sagte in Schwung
gebracht
diesen letzten Test von Behördenseite
hat das Karussell schon mal bestanden
die Gäste können also kommen
hier zu lernen lässt der Schneefall im
Westen nach wie es morgen und am Sonntag
weitergeht erfahren Sie gleich von Katja
horneffer im heute-journal um 10 spricht
Marietta Slomka mit Agnes Strack
Zimmermann der Vorsitzenden des
Verteidigungsausschusses im Bundestag
wir sagen tschüss wünschen Ihnen ein
sehr schönes Wochenende und freuen uns
wenn Sie morgen wieder dabei sind alles
gute
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird ein winterliches
Wochenende und das liegt an diesem Tief
über Südosteuropa denn das bringt vor
allen Dingen in der Nacht zu Sonntag und
Sonntag über Tag neue Schneefälle die
sich von Brandenburg bis nach
Baden-Württemberg ausbreiten auch heute
Nacht schneit es noch in Rheinland-Pfalz
und dem Saarland besonders dort sollten
sie sich auf gefährlich rutschige
Straßen gefasst machen auch sonst kann
es glatt werden und sehr eisig hier z.B
im Sauerland sinken die Temperaturen
über Schnee bis minus 10 Grad auf den
Ostfriesischen Inseln bleibt es mit 0
Grad milder und morgen ziehen dann die
Schneefälle sich erstmal nach Süden
zurück aber dann kommt mit diesem neuen
tief neuer Schnee heran der bereitet
sich schon Richtung Sachsen Thüringen
und Bayern aus für viele wird das noch
mal ein freundlicher Samstag zwischen
Nordfriesland und der Mosel sehen sie
häufig die Sonne bei einem Wind aus
nördlichen bis nordwestlichen Richtungen
so bleibt es kalt im dauerschleifer an
den Alpen werden nur minus vier Grad
erreicht 5 Grad sind es dagegen auf
Rügen der Sonntag bringt uns dann mehr
Schnee freundlicher sieht es hier im
Nordwesten aus bei Temperaturen von -2
bis plus 4 Grad und die neue Woche
startet dann deutlich ruhiger ich
wünsche Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende